got some breaking news to bring you now
with regard to the former cricketer
azeem rafiq who of course has been
making headlines this week after
speaking about his experiences of racism
in the sport of cricket azim rafiq has
just issued an apology
for historic anti-semitic messages
now these were messages that he put on
social media back in 2011
he has apologized and deleted
the exchange this is what azeem rafiq
has had to say within the last few
minutes he said i was sent an image of
this exchange from early 2011 today i
have gone back to check my account and
it is me i have absolutely no excuses i
am ashamed of this exchange and have now
deleted it so as not to cause further
offense i was 19 at the time and i hope
and believe i am a different person
today i am incredibly angry at myself
and i apologize to the jewish community
and everyone who is rightly offended by
this um that was a statement issued by
the former yorkshire cricketer who has
been praised this week for his courage
in exposing
institutional racism in sports as he
said there this was an exchange that
took place when he was 19 he insists he
is a different person today and has
deleted the exchange um you know of
course
many of you will have watched azeem
rafiq's testimony um to the department
of culture media and sports select
committee about his experience of what
he has called institutional racism
within the game of cricket detailing his
experiences at yorkshire county cricket
club uh where
he was
experienced where he experienced people
calling him the p word um and at the
time it was excused as banter there was
an investigation into yorkshire county
cricket club uh the findings of which
are yet to be fully released but azeem
rafiq
decided to speak out publicly he has
been hailed for his bravery as a
whistleblower and it has sent shockwaves
through the world of cricket it started
an open discussion in fact uh all 18
first-class counties are meeting
tomorrow along with the england and
wales cricket board and the professional
cricketers association to come up with
an action plan a rapid action plan um to
promote more inclusion diversity uh in
the sport so um that is a bit of a twist
in the tale azeem rafiq apologizing
today for anti-semitic comments he made
back in
2011 as he said i was 19 at the time and
i hope and believe i am a different
person i apologize to the jewish
community and everyone who is rightly
offended by this